it's Friday and that means it's time for
Friday volleys for that we turn to five
please contributor Raymond Arroyo
Raymond you have a follow-up from last
night about the Democrat mayor of New
Orleans that is right Rachel last night
we told everybody about New Orleans
Mayor Latoya Cantrell appearing in court
to support a recidivist young carjacker
while offering Comfort to the perp and
his mother she ignored the victim who
publicly complained now the mayor
insists she said God bless you to the
victims on her way out of the courtroom
and damn it that's enough
do not discount or God bless you
because for me I'm very spiritual I walk
in faith and I believe when I say when I
say God bless you I'm actually
reciting even a a Hail Mary you have no
idea what's going on uh in in that
connection oh it's a it's a whole mass
and a novena when she says God bless you
it's called using religion to mask your
support of criminality I mean that's
what's Happening Here Rachel yeah it
definitely looks like that now as the
City of New Orleans has become the
murder capital of the country mayor
Kittrell took a trip to France she did
in June and it cost taxpayers forty
thousand dollars now she says you
misunderstand this was a major
diplomatic Mission this is France
you talking about France from which
we've come meaning a part of the fabric
of the City of New Orleans you're
talking about France that has an
ambassador living in the city of New
Orleans you're talking about France that
has supported a full-time position on
resiliency for the City of New Orleans
because we're on the front lines of
climate change and I do travel business
class absolutely I need to be protected
I need to be safe as I do business on
behalf of the City of New Orleans
we come from France only she was born in
L.A no one's doubting New Orleans
connection to France the question is
should the mayor be going there during a
city-wide crisis for Rachel by the way
her safety was so important so dire her
security was several rows behind her in
coach so for liberals Raymond safety
just means you're wearing a mask so they
were in coach wearing a mask by the way
they were safe and I have a little news
tonight a recall effort has been
launched against mayor Cantrell tonight
it was filed with the Secretary of State
in Louisiana and her trip to Singapore
sidelined after this fracas all right
well speaking of Bad actors Hollywood
has once again pledged its allegiance to
to China yeah well according to reports
on the social media site weibo the
Chinese version of minions I'm sure you
saw this many times the rise of group
includes an alternative sanitized
version in the American version the two
main villains Escape at the end
unpunished thus the rise of group but
China wanted to convey a different
message so they slipped in an epilogue
stating that one villain was caught by
police and served 20 years in prison the
other villain changed his ways and
became a good guy I guess if there was
another villain he would have just been
sent to the internment camp I was just
gonna say did they go to a weaker
concentration camp maybe they were just
visiting for a little while but you know
hats off to Sony and to um uh Paramount
who did the Spider-Man movie in the Top
Gun movie they refused to bow to the
Chinese censors they kept their movies
intact that's what they all should do
and they made a lot of money doing it
the biggest movies of the Year finally
Rachel I know you're a big fan of AI rap
okay uh so this news what is that you're
pretty hard that's uh I know what you
mean okay earlier this month Capital
Records signed a robot rapper called FN
Mecca
[Music]
lovely as riveting as there was the
label has done a 180 on the robot
cutting old ties to him uh apparently
artificial intelligence used to devise
Mecca's wraps perpetuated harmful
stereotypes Rachel including several
instances of the n-word well the music
group released a statement this week
saying uh you know that they were they
were separating ties they were so sorry
they apologized deepest apologies to the
black community for the insensitivity of
signing this project my questions are
who programmed this thing right secondly
since it was based on popular existing
rap what did they think they were going
to get Rogers and Hammerstein I mean
yeah it is part of the whole way they do
their thing I was worried that they were
saying that just hiring a robot instead
of an actual black rapper was racist and
then I got nervous because I have a
Roomba does that make me a racist if I
have a robot well only if it talks and
only if there are you you create an
essentially uh uh a person of color
robot with no black people on the
creative team that's what they did here
so capitals during the big walk back
they should have said the beginning yeah
well okay I I just like real people to
sing rap or do whatever you're gonna do
and we can adjust that AI all right real
people I'm down with that all right
Raymond thanks hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else